thanks from Winona for sponsoring this
video I talked to Sam this morning he
said Jake it'll be great
buying a lightsaber in my life well
guess what they brought them down here
hooked us up
we got Jedi challenges we're gonna play
it's gonna be great Lenovo and Disney
made made this product called Jedi
challenges augmented reality game
you hold the lightsaber hilt and the
screen tracks the environment projects
lightsaber blade out into the
environment where you get to hold it and
see it in front of your very own dad Sam
once spent 3 months doing lifesaver
effects I thought that long in the grand
scheme of things but when you're 14
that's like a serious that's like 5% of
your life span frame-by-frame get hit
with the lightsaber in the game for the
hurt what is the tracking beacon you put
it in the middle and this is basically
what the AR headset uses to track the
figures that you fight against look when
I go to parties I just carry this with
me I'm like okay
[Music]
thank you all right we had dieters the
thing is while he was out spinning and
chopping them up I was getting flat I'm
gonna not do that this stuff tonight but
yeah I'm gonna go on a different plan
boys dude on the place of snipers oh
here we go they're like speeder bike
troopers
[Music]
I think this is some pretty cool biz I
here you go look Oh funny you like
literally shop there Adam they just got
a little little droid head this was dang
oh you like straight-up shut them up
Chavez Lego yep dude this is great it's
like you're like like a sushi chef I win
[Music]
that was fun fighting Jedi's and droids
but there's only one thing to do now
take it to the next level
[Music]
dogmeat closer to their goals I'm right
up in your face start Ren's gonna
attempt to fight Darth Vader on top of a
wheel or reenacting the scene from
Revenge of the Sith where they're
floating on the log and fighting each
other exactly they're all in the high
ground clearly it is Nobita superb
really if you fall off the wheel it's a
hambone then what no work for disabling
the memo for this game it's brought me
good I'm a swimmer
[Music]
I could breathe under leva okay
I mean it's not possible though ya know
hambone though alright there's another
game type Nico's really eager to try it
it's called strategic combat dependence
truth blowing on guys up we had some
leaders here rally the troops there we
go sexpot all right cool
unlike placing troops on the ground
we depend these towers plum that ATSC
there we go they're heavy here the six
minutes ground
more troops signal
he's kind of cool it's all track here
[Music]
in troops
rebel base defended unlike all schools
at ha I did my job correctly you know
there was actually there's like a
Sabrina when Wren in there like yeah
it's like your sister your daughter what
you doing there boy Oh what up dude
[Music]
you've been here all night
what what time is it so in the morning
oh shoot I didn't really get to
participate in the Jedi challenge so it
looked really cool so I figured I just I
don't know I thought I was just staying
late after work and uh figured I'd check
out some hollow chests is it really 7:00
in the morning 7 good morning again oh
well I'm kind of like killing it at this
chess game I think I got really good at
it this game is really addicted once
again thanks to Lenovo for inviting us
to try out this device and for bringing
the Jedi experience to life like never
before
remember it's an AR smartphone powered
piece of technology meaning that there
are more updates to come if you guys are
interested in checking it out go to
jenna challenges comm find out more have
fun thank you for watching
carmichael be safe man be safe now